when we first started talking about
central tendencies and how we measure
average we talked about the arithmetic
mean and there you just added up the
numbers and you divide by the number of
numbers there were so let's say our
population of numbers is see we have a
3. so we have three threes
a four
and a five that's our population and if
we wanted the
population mean here we would just add
all the numbers up we'd say three plus
three
plus three
plus 4
plus 5 and then we would divide that sum
by the number of numbers we have
right we would divide that
by 5. and we would come let's see
would this be this would be 9 plus nine
it would be eighteen over five that
would be eighteen
over five which would be what three
and
three and three fifths which is three
point six is the population mean for
this population of numbers if we just
rearrange the math here a little bit we
could view it a slightly different way
how many threes do we have we have three
three so we could view this as
three times three
how many fours do we have we have one 4
so it's plus
1 times 4
plus 1 times 5
plus 1 times 5 all of that divided by 5.
and then what we could do is this is the
same thing and i'm just doing a little
bit of basic
really number manipulation here this is
the same thing as one-fifth
times
three
times three plus one times four
plus
one times five
and then if we distribute this one-fifth
this is equal to what
three-fifths
times three
plus one-fifth times one so it's plus
one-fifth
times four plus one fifth times five
plus one fifth
times five and just so we can see in a
bunch of different ways let me express
these as
as decimals so three-fifths that's so
it's .6
times three plus point
two
times four
plus
point two
times five or we could you know we could
express these decimals as percentage we
could say sixty percent
times three
plus twenty percent
sorry twenty percent
times four
plus
twenty percent
times five this is identical to adding
up the numbers and then dividing by the
total number of numbers there are right
but this is interesting because here we
had to know
how many total numbers there are right
we had to say okay there we added up
five numbers we divide by five
all i did is i changed the i played
around with the arithmetic a little bit
and i got to this expression but this
expression is more interesting right or
at least it's well it's different it's
not necessarily more interesting i don't
want to make any value judgment about it
but here i don't know how many numbers
there are i'm just telling you about the
frequency of the numbers i'm telling you
that sixty percent of the numbers are
three twenty percent of the numbers are
four and then twenty percent of the
numbers are a five and then if i were to
calculate this out i would get sixty
percent times three is one point eight
plus twenty percent times four is point
eight
plus twenty percent times five is let's
see twenty percent plus one which would
be equal to two point six plus one is
equal to three 3.6 so we would get the
exact same number but what's interesting
here is that this tells you just the
frequencies really the relative
frequencies of the threes the fours and
the fives what percentage of this
population is threes sixty percent what
population what percentage is four is
twenty percent and what population is
fives and i'm doing that because we've
just talked about random variables and
all of that
and in the beginning we started our
statistics discussion about populations
and samples but if you think about it
every time you get kind of your you you
do one of your experiments and you get a
new value for a random val variable
right let's say you know our our let's
let's do our classical example we have
our random variable x is equal to
i don't know
it's equal to the number
number of heads
after
six tosses
of fair coin
of a fair coin so that's a random
variable so
hopefully now we can kind of connect
what we thought about in terms of just
arithmetic mean and central tendency and
population versus sample and then
and then connect that to the notion of a
random variable so when we when we first
started talking about statistics we said
okay you know you have this notion of a
of a population
and that you would sample the population
and we gave a couple of examples you
know the most common one is you wanted
to predict the the
outcome of a presidential election the
population is everyone who's going to
vote in the election you can't survey
all you know
50 million people who whatever is going
to vote for the election so what you do
is you survey
a random sample right of that population
and then you you can calculate
statistics on that sample that hopefully
can estimate the population as a whole
but what happens if the population is
not finite
right and just to go back you know if
you if the population is finite you can
calculate things like the population
mean right we we learned the population
mean was that mu letter and that was you
just literally take up all of the
all of the items in the population add
them together and you divide by the
number of items there are
that's what we did up here right if this
was the whole population of numbers we
figured out that this was mu if this was
a sample from a population then this
would be the sample mean but we learned
all about that but that's not what i
want to get at now but what happens
what happens
if this population is infinite if it's
infinite and you're like oh sal that
doesn't make any sense but if you think
about it it well
a random variable
really is
the the population it's it's you can
kind of view it as each instance of a
random variable or every time you
perform the experiment you're taking out
an instance of an infinite population
right you can perform this experiment an
infinite number of times
you can just keep doing it it's not like
you know after doing it a thousand times
you're like oh you can't toss six uh a
coin six times anymore and count the
number of heads you can perform this
indefinitely right so every specific
result from a random variable and those
are usually lowercase results you know
lower lower case x1 or x2 or x3
these are just you know specific
instances of a random variable you can
view these as samples from an infinite
population
right so i'll try to draw an infinite
population it's kind of harder maybe
i'll draw arrows that go off in every
direction this population never ends you
can keep performing the experiment and
keep getting samples
but your sample is usually finite
and this would be our
you know let's say we perform this
experiment we we toss a fair coin six
times and we do that experiment i don't
know we do it a hundred times so then we
would have a hundred samples
x2 and it would go all the way to x100
right
and the reason why i'm doing this
connection is one to make you see the
connection between the random variable
and the probability and the statistics
that we talked about earlier
and in this video i'm going to introduce
you to the concept of the expected value
of a random variable and it's nothing
else so the expected value of a random
variable
the expected value of a random variable
is is the exact same thing as the
population mean in fact sometimes it's
called a population mean but what makes
it interesting is in this situation you
have an infinite population right so you
can't just add up all the numbers and
divide by the number of numbers you have
because you have an infinite number of
numbers but what you can do is if you
said wow but i know the frequency of the
numbers
right i know that you know 3 shows up 60
of the time 4 shows up 20 of the time
five shows up twenty percent of time
then even if you have an infinite number
of numbers you can actually still
calculate a mean and that's how you do
it for for an expected value for of a
random variable so how do you figure out
the frequencies that numbers show up
well you can look at the the probability
distribution the uh
the discrete probability distribution so
listen in that example that we did
last time i forgot the exact numbers but
actually let me just take our what we
did
our excel out i know let me just quickly
i want to make n
six trials
proper probability of heads tails okay
0.5
and then i need to change where this
chart
is give me one second
change what the inputs of this chart are
let me just
i'm off the screen right now
okay there you go so this is the
probability distribution for what i just
described i have a fair uh toss of a
coin and i want to know how many heads i
have after six tosses right so you can
perform this experiment a bunch of times
but this tells you the frequency the
frequency of how of of that random
variable so when you perform that
experiment let's see you know what
whatever this is 0.09 percent of the
time so not actually 9 of the time
you're going to get exactly one head if
you look 23 of the time you're gonna get
two heads
31 of the time you're going to get three
heads
23 percent of time you're going to get
you're going to get four heads and then
you know nine percent of time you're
gonna get five heads and then six
percent and then two percent of time
you're going to get six heads so if you
have that information you can then
actually figure out the the population
mean for this population that's
described by this probability
distribution or the expected value and
let's do that right here i'll put this
over to the side
so i'm looking at that chart i just did
while i do this so if
this if
we just looked at the probability
distribution for this random variable
the number of heads after six tosses of
a fair coin
so the expected value
the expected value of our random
variable is going to be
each outcome so the first outcome is you
know xc that we hit zero heads times the
frequency that zero shows up so we
figured out before that the frequency
well it's a little inexact because i
don't have the actually i have the exact
numbers let me
the frequency
so
we get
0 will show up in our random variable
0.01563 percent of the time so let me
write that
so we're going to say well this happens
and i can write as a percentage
1.563 percentage of the time
plus
1 happens
one happens
nine point three seven five percent of
the time
and then plus two happens
twenty three point four three eight
percentage of the time
plus three happens
three happens let's see it says 31
0.25 percent of the time almost there
four i get four heads out of six tosses
23 percent of the time times 23.438
percent
i get five heads after six tosses
nine point three seven five percent of
the time and finally i get all heads
i get all heads
let's see nine
no i get all heads one point five six
three percent of the time one point five
six three and that makes sense again
because all heads should just be should
be just as likely as all tails right all
tails the same thing as no heads so what
we did here is exactly what we did
up here where up here
we took the relative frequency of each
of the numbers in the population and we
multiply that outcome times its relative
frequency and we're adding it up but
this is the exact same thing
mathematically as we did up here but
what's useful now
is we can apply the same principles but
we're finding the the arithmetic mean of
an infinite population or the expected
value of a random variable which is the
same thing as the arithmetic mean of
this of the population of this random
variable
so this value would be equal to
actually let me just
use excel to calculate it
so the expected value
of getting
of the number of heads you get after six
tosses so this will be see i want to do
so this is zero times its frequency
and then
i'm going to add them all up or and then
this will just do that same thing all of
it so this says
this will be 1 times its frequency 2
times this frequency and then if i were
to take the sum of all of them
equal sum
of all of these
i get let me add some
let me yeah
i get exactly three
so that's it and that's actually kind of
an expected outcome right i shouldn't
use the word expected too much
that the central tendency or you could
say the population mean
of this random variable or you could say
the expected value of this random
variable is exactly three and that in
this example it turned out that 3 is
also in kind of the colloquial sense
it's the most expected value right it's
the most probable value but we'll see in
the future that the expected value
doesn't have to be the most probable
value you could have you know a very
high probability of having no heads and
a very high probability of having six
heads and then you'd still have an
expected value of three even if six or
zero were more probable and i'll show
you more examples of that but the
purpose of this video is to really show
you
is to really show you that the expected
value calculation
is the same thing as the population mean
calculation but we do it this way
because you can't add up an infinite
number of of data points and divide by
an infinite number instead you want to
know the frequencies of each of the
outcomes and then you just
add up all the outcomes weighted by
their frequencies but that's no
different than what you did up there and
i really want to hit that point home
because sometimes in probability books
they'll just give you a formula oh the
expected value for probability
distribution is each of the outcomes
times their frequency but i want to show
you that that is the same thing as the
population mean anyway see in the next
video